hey guys
this year has passed so quickly and the
next one is right around the corner
and when we come to the end of the year
it is good to look back
on this previous year everything that
has happened
and reflect to learn from our mistakes
and then to make some personal
adjustments
life is always going to throw you ups
and downs that's never going to change
but what you can change
is you yourself
and if you do that it'll change the way
that you look at and handle
the challenges that this life throws at
you for many people a good place to
start is new year's resolutions so in
this video i'm gonna give you my 10 best
new year resolutions that men should
consider let's get to it
[Music]
now just very quick if you're new to my
channel my name is daniel and welcome to
dln men's lifestyle now let's start with
number one
[Music]
get in shape
you only get one body and one life in
this temporary world so be honest take a
hard look at yourself in the mirror
and ask yourself
are you happy with what you see in the
mirror
if not then do something about it hit
the gym do home workouts or go jogging
get active get fit get healthy and start
respecting yourself
stop your bad addiction
whatever it is if it's holding you back
and if it's bad for your health quit
smoking drinking drugs porn gambling
whatever it is stop it don't you think
it is time to become more responsible
and have self-control
you don't want to be a slave of
something that is controlling you
be a real man by taking good care of
yourself and then you can be an example
to your friends and your family be that
guy that other people look up to
stop procrastinating
think back on this last year what did
you really do
what did you accomplish
did you work hard for your future that
you invest in it by working smart and
hard or were you lazy if you have goals
that you want to achieve in life but you
don't put in the work to achieve them
it's just not gonna happen
it's just gonna stay a nice dream
and here's the thing
if you don't put in the work if you
don't work hard
for what you wanna achieve
no one else in the world is gonna do it
for you
so stop procrastinating
get your wardrobe in order
it's time to let go of all those clothes
all those accessories
that you never wear and when you need to
buy new stuff get things that are
actually good quality and it will last
you a long time slowly just change over
to a high quality and stylish wardrobe
that will give people a good first
impression no matter what you choose to
wear
[Music]
become more independent
are you one of those guys who you just
need people to help you with things all
the time can you make proper meals by
yourself can you travel by yourself
how about washing clothes and what about
the dishes
are you really a responsible person that
takes responsibility when you mess up
are you a real man or are you still a
boy
i'm not being rude here with you guys
i'm just being straight with you and you
need to look in the mirror and be honest
with yourself as well
[Music]
prioritize sleep i talked about it so
many times on my channel i'm not going
to do it again here and go all
scientific on you but don't you think
it's time to take good care of yourself
by getting
good quality sleep every night to get in
a good quality sleeping routine is going
to impact your health your brain power
and also your emotions
explore the world
are you just always staying in your
comfort zones
why
why not just go places instead of just
going always to your favorite coffee
shop or your favorite park
go and explore
go out and explore more meet new people
see new things
and when is holiday go and see new
places in and outside of your country
save more money
stop wasting your money on things that
you don't have to you know there's a lot
of guys and i complain and i say well i
don't have enough money
well they don't have enough money
because they spend it on things that are
unnecessary saving money is not
difficult all you got to do is this the
money that you give out should always be
less than the money that you get in that
way your bank account is always going to
grow be responsible and plan for the
future
get a bucket list
now you guys know that i've been doing
this recently on my videos
and i think it's so important you gotta
write down a list of things that you
want to do before you die it's a lot of
guys walking around they breathe but
they don't actually live life
you gotta have life and have it
abundantly so make a list of things that
you want to do and then just go for it
become a better person
you have the power to make your own
decisions and choose how you want to
live your life there are enough arrogant
selfish and just plain bad people out
there that makes this world a bad place
be the change that you want to see in
the world it all starts with you focus
on your values your character your
personality and your actions
now just some last advice personally
i don't like new year's resolutions
because let's be honest
i usually don't last for most people
that's why it's more important to make
life resolutions where you change your
life permanently take some time and
think about your life and what you need
to change to go into the future and then
just do it
and always remember life is short
so don't waste yours cheers guys
[Applause]